and I'm back hello everyone and sorry
for a mission and trying to get my
machine to run everybody having a good
day
not not at my level where your machine
Mack blue screens right before your
presentation so I'm going to be talking
about or really ever since angular today
and not my last thingamajig doesn't work
ah there is my name is Chris Luke I say
I work as a software developer /
architect / mentor / presenter at a
company called Nova trucks division in
in Stockholm and I spend most of my time
it feels like running around the
different conferences and trying to give
away knowledge and experiences I've
learnt along the way and then once in a
while I try to go to actually clients
and build stuff unfortunately not as
much as I'd hoped but that's what it is
uhm and I am from Sweden so anybody in
here not Swedish
pretty much all of you and that causes
problems because Swedish people don't
speak English natively so if I start
going bork bork bork in the marital
everything and you don't understand what
I'm saying we have two options right
option number one you put your arm up
and you interrupt me and you ask me what
I just said I will repeat it once again
you won't understand it that time either
I'm embarrassed you get no more
information doesn't seem like a
fantastic idea right sucks for me option
number two you hear bork bork bork you
go okay he's Swedish I understand enough
to understand the gist of what he's
saying I'm just going to leave it okay
so we've got two options
I prefer option number two you just let
it slide if you don't want to let it
slide that's fine just remember I am
from Sweden so my ancestry is this guy
and when you start interrupting me
there's just one thing you need to
remember just going to say that
seriously if there's anything you don't
understand just go ahead and interrupt
me I will try and explain and I'm
actually a very nice guy and if not then
you can come up and ask me afterwards
what I was spelling out but it
the topic of today is a really emerged
angular and first question is actually
the first listen to you guys we're going
to do the classical nerd workouts which
is race one arm and how many people are
doing a relay development today how many
people are doing angular development
today how many have never touched any of
these frameworks okay that's a good mix
mostly angular little really and a bunch
of people have never seen the different
works and so well I think I'll cover
it's in the way where everybody
understands what I'm saying so what are
they well it's kind of simple I think
most of you guys would know that they
are actually JavaScript frameworks duh
and what happened is that I've worked
quite a bit with angular I've built
angularjs applications and angular 2 / 4
/ whatever they call it nowadays
formerly known as angular 2 applications
since well basically since they went
live with it and and then I do a bit
over reallya and I thought it's kind of
interesting to compare these frameworks
because once you start working with them
you realize that they have a lot of
similarities and a couple of one of the
team members from the angular team
actually moved over and started or real
yet so there's a bit of crossbreeding
between them and I thought well let's
have a look at why you would choose
either/or
so I and I could pick up the things that
I felt when I pick them up a new
framework what is interesting to me so I
don't really care what you think it's
just me and it's what I care about so
this is my session ok so I'll cover this
things that I I had in mind and but I've
been doing I've been a trainer for a
full-time trainer for two years I know
pretty much the questions that you
normally get asked I thought I'd answer
those they are JavaScript frameworks but
they have a little bit of a difference
in how they look at JavaScript so if you
look at angular I'm going to be on the
angular sides to begin with on most
cases because most of you guys have
worked on angular or know what angular
is and angular went ahead and it built
their angular 2 and said we're going to
build everything in typescript we're
going to go 100% typescript we're going
to embrace typescript we're going to
work together with Microsoft to make
typescript better and make typescript
something that we can use to build our
system
and but they also said synthesizer type
scripts and type script trance files to
ECMO script you might as well go and
write it in pure ECMO script if you want
as well so you can go and write angular
applications in ECMO script six if you
want to as well but by default they will
type script everything so if you go into
the angular and documentation size they
will have typescript examples for you
that's basically what they will show you
and then you have to actively go and say
I want echo script on though really
aside is a little bit different or
really I said heck no we're not doing
typescript we're going to do echo script
six it's good enough it's standard based
we'll use that and then they said we
have that but we do understand people
liking typescript so we will add
typescript supports so they have
typescript support by definite
typescript definite definitions for
aurélia but it's not written in
typescript which is sort of a difference
and when you go into the documentation
documentation will actually default to
echo script when you create a new
project using the CLI they will default
to echo script so it's a little bit
focus difference to be perfectly honest
I think protected how many people are
doing typescript today how many people
are doing extra script how many people
wish they were doing type script that
was a whole lot okay the thing is XS
script is fine there's nothing wrong
with that my script I actually like
JavaScript I'm one of the few people
that find it quite cool to work with but
if you do X my script six it's not going
to run anywhere while it's going to run
and know it but it's not going to run in
your browser so if you want to something
that runs in the browser you actually
have to go and transpile it right so if
you write eggman script six you have to
throw through horrible to get echo
script five to run in your browser if
you write type scripts you have to throw
it at the typescript compiler and the
typescript compiler gives us much good
for us in the browser my personal
opinion and this is my session so my
personal opinion is the only thing that
matters in here is that typescript
offers us some features that are kind of
cool we get static typing and with
static typing we get a bunch of tooling
we get a bunch of help we get interfaces
we get classes we got a bunch of stuff
that we're used to working with if we
come from a c-sharp world for example
but there's nothing that says that you
have to write type script in a type
script file if you change a type
JavaScript file written in correct
JavaScript from Jas to dot TS it becomes
a type script file and it becomes
typescript you're not using typescript
but you've got all of the power in there
if you want to so if you choose to go
the typescript path you can use
typescript where it makes sense where do
I want to have static typing where do I
need tooling to make this easier to use
and what part of it am I going to go
completely dynamic flexible JavaScript
weird since I could stuff that nobody
can ever follow along in two weeks and
build these amazing things that only
JavaScript can do and you can just mix a
nudge in XML script six you're kind of
stuck with one thing in typescript you
can mix as much as you want having said
that you can clearly understand that I
love gel a subscript and I will write
everything I can in typescript they also
have slightly different architectural
views and everything so angular said
we're going to build components
components is the way forward everybody
wants components web components this web
component that really I said we're not
doing components we're doing mvvm so
anybody want to give me the difference
between mvvm and components I will tell
you the difference is in components you
have a bunch of code UI code written in
typescript or JavaScript and you have a
view and you connect the code with the
view with a binding context and they are
a unit that is then rendered in your
browser right yes Chris that's right
mvvm means that you have a bunch of a
bit of code written in typescript or
JavaScript and you have a view and then
you put those together using a binding
context and then you render them in the
browser as a unit so it's the same thing
no it's not the same thing they have
different names it's there there is a
bit more to it but it's kind of kind of
interesting because there's very little
difference and components the main
difference is that components will
actually say this is my I'm not going to
call it view model because it's a
component but basically this is my code
and then as part of my code I decorated
with decorator and say together with
this code I want to use this template
to do the rendering and then they're
basically join together as one unit and
they will stay together for the rest of
their lives mvvm says I will have a view
model with all of my code I will have a
view and they will sit together but
there's nothing saying that this view
model here has to fit together with this
view here so I can go ahead and say I
have four different views doing the same
thing using the same view models but
with different layouts and then I can
mix and match and say can I have that
view model over there with that view
over there and put those together so in
theory you can go ahead and say if
you're on a tablet actually if you're on
the phone I will give you one UI it's
still going to be the same view model
but on the phone I have something that
just doesn't make sense
so I will have a view that doesn't
include some of the buttons because you
won't do that on the phone but if you're
on a full machine with the world's
largest laptop or screen and you running
with world's highest connection to the
Internet and all of that you can go and
say I'm going to have this other nasty
view that has all of the functionality
but they both connect to the same UI
logic does that make sense so that's
kind of cool right has that ever
happened I don't know I have a
background in Silverlight don't laugh at
me it was it was a good choice when I
made it no it wasn't but it should have
been and we did a lot of a medium and I
don't know an MVP MVP MVP mmm work and
looked a lot at my VM and thought it was
kind of cool and I've gone around the
world talking about it and said it's
kind of cool because you can switch out
the UI for and the view model you can
mix and match if you want and I have
built a bunch of applications for
sylvite and WF and you don't mix and
match it just doesn't happen it's a cool
selling point but honestly no but if you
do you can do it in your really aside
but not angular so if you look at the
code for that right-hand side you got
your class with your you are logic it's
a very stupid class it doesn't that's
you have a lot of logic in this case but
it could have in my components and then
in my decorator I say that this is a
component and you will find the template
at this path so they are strictly
connected together one-to-one where it's
on the earlier side I can use
an element called compost say this is
where you will find my view model which
is to pass to my JavaScript file and you
can then get the path to the view that
you want to use using view dot mind and
say go and get this view over here and
then you can have logic in there that
renders figures out what view to render
for that thing is supple this kind of
it's a little bit more flexible there
are also two modular frameworks so in
angular you do all of these inputs at
the top you have this import this and
import that and import it feels like
importing a gazillion things from a
bunch of different component modules and
you end up with two three maybe four
different inputs at the top for angular
doing getting different things from
different modules to tell you what
you're doing like I don't get a
component from core and I will get the
router from the router module and I
might probably not pull out my platform
browser but I'm not going to pull out
the HDP or something like that and I
will have these on different lines and
no real yeah it's kind of nice because
we only have one module there's like one
ubirr module that has everything where
you go I want to get all of these things
and just get it from the really module
and I don't care that it's a modular
framework just give me whatever it is I
want that sounds awesome because it's
just one input at the top and I kind of
like having few rows at the top because
my code comes faster in the file and I
found this quite interesting so I had to
dig and scratch the surface a little bit
and it's awesome because the aurélia
framework file looks like this it's
basically just re exporting all of the
other modules in the whole system
so if you like the one import statement
at the top that really has go and write
a file like this for angular and you're
done with it so you can have exactly the
same feature in angular it's just it's
not there by default they they both also
require external dependencies that you
need to add other dependencies to get
your framework to work so in the angular
size you need to go and get zoned ojs
which is the way that angular does its
data mining and since angular uses a lot
of observables you tend to go and get
reactive extensions JavaScript as well
because you want to be able to work with
those observables in the native way
on the raelia side they're saying we've
got two requirements or two two
dependencies
the first one is Bluebird so what's blue
bird blue bird is a replacement thingy
for prop the promise implementation in
your web browser because apparently the
promise implementation in Bluebird is
faster than the prom promise
implementation in your browser I have no
idea how they manage to do that but they
did apparently and they have required
yes so if you're building or really out
of the box just stock standard Orillia
it will use requirejs so they will have
a dependency on that framework as well
and then if you might need to support
that that browser that should not be
mentioned you need polyfills as well
there is a browser out there that
requires you to add a bunch of extra
stuff because it works kind of poorly
without so you have a bunch of polyfills
but that's the same on both sides
because they both depend on stuff that
the browser that shall not be named
actually doesn't implement so what's it
like getting started with it because
step number one when you go out from
this session you're just going to
scratch the rest of the afternoon and
start building stuff in a real and
angular right so we're going to sit down
there have burgers and write code so how
did you get started well you go and get
to see like both frameworks come with a
command-line interface that you can use
you've got there really a CLI and you've
got the angular CLI
it's basically just you go npm install
at angular slash CLI g and you're good
and then you go and install NPM install
or really a - PLI - G and you're good on
your machine if you have node installed
and everybody has node that's just kind
of everyone everyone has known so that's
pretty similar except for the fact that
angular only has that option basically
there are other options you can google
it you can go out to the web and try to
find somebody that has a starter project
for you and it's going to fail and then
you go back and use to CLI so just skip
that and get to see light to begin with
oh really yeah actually comes and says
we have skeletons so skeleton is a
starter project that were really has
built for you
supportive they're really a repo if you
can go to their repo and say I want to
build in a really application and I want
to have this combination of things
so really are supports Eggman script and
type scripts they support asp net core
or node and they support what else a web
pack or requirejs
so you decide if you want to go and
build an application that's an asp.net
core application using webpack in
typescript they have a specific skeleton
app for that configuration that you can
get started with which is quite nice in
the angular cases basically here is what
you get I don't care if you want use
ethnic or here is the thing we giving
you which is noted you can also go and
use German which is a generator for
solutions and files anybody use Eamonn
okay so here mine is cool unfortunately
it's kind of falling off the face of the
earth a little bit because nobody cares
anymore
I'm not being mean to those of you who
actually use it because it's actually
good good tool but because everyone is
getting their own CLI people focus on
their C lines that are focused on
getting stuff into another command-line
interface and then yes you have this
sort of project that I mentioned you can
always go in google and say is there
anybody online that has a sort your
project that I can use that fulfills my
requirements that is a cool way of
starting because you will find that guy
that has built that specific combination
that you want but then you download it
and you spend the rest of the week
trying to get it to work and then at the
end of the week you give up and you go
and get the CLI anyway because there's a
lot of movement in both these frameworks
especially I've tried it in angular
there's so much movement in angular that
I often end up when you get started
project and you say oh I have this demo
you can just download and try it you try
to build it and actually explodes
because they haven't kept it updated so
skeleton asturias realize what I
recommend this Eli are well they're both
kind of similar right so you write a you
new to get a new project or ng new you
write a you build or ng build if you
want to build your application a you run
or ng serve if you want to start up the
application and look at it and start an
in memory or in memory brett web browser
a you test ng test around your test
and you generate energy generate you see
they're pretty similar to do it there
are two differences that I thought was
worth highlighting or really actually
supports extensibility so you can easily
in your project go in and create an
extensibility point to do really a
command-line interface and add other
generators so if you have a specific
thing that you want to be able to go out
to the command line and just go eh you
generate my magic cool thing you can
write that code add it to your project
know the sudden you have extended your
CLI with new features and it's all built
around gulp as far as I remember so it's
quite easy to get story with and angular
has another one that I love has anyone
tried a ng eject no one a couple of
hands guys when I go and ask you I tied
it no so ng eject I just had to pull
that out because anger still is a bit
magical because you go and you knew you
create a new project you go as you build
and it builds and it there's really very
little configuration you can do to see
like does everything for you and you're
kind of what's actually happening behind
the things so how many of you when you
install an application and during the
install there's an advanced button in
the install do you click it is one
honest guy two three four there yeah
it's lonely there are more and more
hands going up and the same if I can and
there is an advanced button I have to
click it I can't remember I have one
thing that I keep installing every time
time I repair my machine and when you
press advanced button there is actually
nothing to change I love that I would
just add a message duh so ng eject is my
version of that because ng eject means
that I can go into a CLI projects ang
eject and it generates a web packet
configuration file for me and it tells
the project that you are no longer a CLI
project you cannot build this project
using the angular CLI it's now a web PAC
project and then web pack takes over
because web tag is used by the silane
CLI normally and then when you have that
web pack file you can see everything
that's actually going on and you can go
in and mess it up which is awesome so
the new product is wonder how do you get
started I actually kind of like
because they are slightly different I'm
just going to pull up something useful
here let's go to there there there open
the command line can everybody say that
is that visible in the back people are
nodding people have good eyesight in
Norway so we do a you new now actually
let's start with angular so I'm going to
ng you which is new and angular projects
and this is the angular demo you press
enter and it goes I've created these
files for you and then it goes down here
it says successfully initialized guess I
didn't ask forget I just want to
highlight that and installing packages
for tooling via NPM which is basically
it runs npm install in the background
and it freezes here for a while
very helpful oh really has a different
approach a you new MVC
demo or really a demo that didn't that
didn't come up very well or really I'm
from Sweden I can spell I'm going to
blame being Swedish for everything that
goes wrong so first of all Aurelia comes
up with a secured which gives them one
step ahead in the game of which one is
best
but what I mostly like about this is
this here what do you want to do do you
want to do AF next do you want you to
echo script do you want to use
typescript or do you want to go custom
what do you think I choose oh yeah we go
custom it next one it goes back and says
okay sweet do you want use the bubble
for ECMO script six or do you want to
use typescript I'm going to use
typescript
as you can see bubble actually you might
not be able to see that in the back like
this bubble down here at the default so
I go to I want to go touch good next
question would you like to set up your
how would you like to set up your
templates do you want to have no markup
processing do you want a minimum markup
processing or do you want have maximum
markup processing my opinion on that is
default none seems really boring minimum
seems like chickening out we're going
maximum everything gets better if you
just
max everything and then he goes what CSS
processor do you want to use because we
with nobody writes CSS anymore everybody
writes less or sass or something else
even I do that I'm old-school I write
CSS in a file called left
it's just apparently not very helpful
that it looks cooler so I'm going to
salmon go left - would you like to
configure unit test that is not
happening
what is your default code editor vicious
with your code atom sublime webstorm
none of the above
look how a visual studio is not an
option but this will see your code works
fine for me so I'm going to leave that
and then it goes so these are your
choices this is name your platform the
transpiler you choice and market
processor CSS processor unit test runner
editor is this correct yes and then it
goes do you want so basically I have now
installed the project structure so I
have my entire project structure and I
can go into code and start working on it
but do you also want me to go and do NPM
install for you yes I do and it runs and
cam installs for me down here and you
can actually see what's happening I
supposed to know that just gives you a
green screen green line saying I am
doing something no it should probably be
done by now as or and angular stuff that
works fine so that's the difference
between creating a new project in
angular versus a real yeah and my
personal favorite is obviously Aurelia I
like having choices I don't like
somebody shoving their opinions down my
throat not as I'm shoving my opinion
down your throat because that's a whole
different story
right you guys have paid to come and get
my opinion shove down your throats it's
up to you that's not Michael's so this
is what you get out of a pretty over
here a you knew an engineer so we've got
pretty much the same thing - perfectly
honest it's a JavaScript application or
a typescript application and it uses the
same library so we've got typescript
Lynne thing we've got types of
configuration
we've got package jason because we're
doing NPM stuff we got a karma config
which is on both sides because we've got
karma as the test runner
we've got index.html and
because on this site because really I
goes and says I'm going to serve from
the root of your application those two
files are in the SRC folder in in
angular and we got the editor config
which is same on both sides so there's
protractor is different there's a
protractor on that side it's not one
here if you want to do end-to-end
testing in a real yet you use you use
protractor on this side as well so
basically you've got the same thing it's
a slightly different way of doing it and
and also the fact that index.html is
inside the source folder has to do with
how the in memory web browser works in
in angular but on this leaks pretty much
the similar this is a same thing and if
you look at the angular CLI of Jason
that's where you configure all of this
real-life stuff for Jason or for angular
in Jason all of that configuration is
available inside or really under script
project instead for Aurelia so even the
configuration is pretty much they've got
the same configuration possibilities in
both projects so what's it like coding
in the frameworks because I assume that
once you create your project you do
actually want to code because you don't
want to have an application that says
hello world which is what you get out of
that's what you get from a really
angular it's a little bit more low-key
and says app works so building stuff is
is also based on two ideas it's
convention versus configuration so oh
really I said oh it's rather let's start
with angular angular has a bit of a
feeling of we're developers we need to
get working sorry I'm not well I'm
normally something like this here I
think it's not like presenting in the US
where they get annoyed when saying stuff
like that it feels like anger glands
we're going to get stuff done how do we
put these things together I need to get
this how do I configure all of it and
they wrote this configurable API which
is it's nice there's nothing wrong with
it it just feels like a real I went and
said actually we know what you guys are
going to be doing most of the time you
will be writing view models and views
and why would you have to go and
register everything and configure
everything because you're still going to
be naming your views according to some
form of convention and you're going to
be naming your view models according to
some form of
invention so how about we just say that
if your view model is named su j s or
dotted TS and your view is called foo
dot HTML why shouldn't I be able to
figure that out on my own and it does so
basically you don't have to go and say
these things long these things belong
together or really it just goes by
convention it says due to what somebody
has told me this is what I should be
looking for which is quite nice and and
if you look at things like bootstrapping
good example of convention based work in
Orillia if you start actually I'm going
to start in anger I don't know why I put
angular on the wrong side all the time
in the bottom but let's start with
angular first of all he has import
platform browser dynamic that took me
while before I sort of really understood
with that main man but it means my
application is going to run in a browser
and I want to dynamically compile my
JavaScript as it runs basically just
compiling the thing and making it slow
and then I need to import my module
where I have my route module with all my
functionality and then I could go and
tell the platform prices that I make
that I want to bootstrap my application
using this module and then in that
module I have to register what thing I
can bootstrap with and in my view I have
to add like an element like this saying
that this is where you should be
bootstrapping me and start your
application not very complicated but a
few steps oh really I has a different
approach in the body tag you create and
really a dash app attributes and you say
main and then you had a script tag and
you point to vendor button bundles
vendor - bundle ojs with a data main
really - bootstrapper that's it
there's no extra elements there's
nothing telling it what module to load
and all of that you're basically saying
in main that means main dot j s is going
to go to main download name - j s in
there is a bit of configuration on how
to set up earlier for your application
and after it's run main J s it goes and
says you didn't tell me what to load so
I'm just going to go and download a file
called after J s because that's probably
what you want it to be called then it
goes into this after J s and it loads
that new model and then it lower
says since you won
load up the dais and you didn't tell me
anything else you probably want me to
download after the HTML as well and then
they join the view model with the view
and the binding context and they insert
into the body tag and you're done so
it's a lot of stuff going on but you
don't have to care as long as you name
things right it just works
they've also got modules for modules in
angular and features in Orillia so in
angular everything is a module
everything has to belong somewhere
module is like a box where you throw all
the things you've built inside of it and
a module is a class which has an NG
module module decorator and you say
inside this module you can find a
component called my component and
anybody that takes a year dependency on
this module called my module are allowed
to use the my component and then in my
other module I go and say in this module
that I'm creating I want to go ahead and
use that under module over there and I
have to explicitly say every single
module that I wanted to load or really
has a different approach they're
basically saying we'll use something
called features and the feature is a
folder so you create a folder with the
name of the feature that you want to use
the feature name you want and inside
that folder you create a file called
index or PS and you create a export one
function called configure and you take
the framework configuration and in there
you basically say I'm a feature and here
are the things that I'm offering up for
everyone else to use and once you've
created the different features that you
want so you got one for user maintenance
and one for or user handling and you've
got one for signing in and one for
article handling and stuff like that
you just go ahead and say in your main
CS file you say oh really I do sort
feature and you give it the name of the
folder that you want to load and it
automatically figures everything else
components I mentioned the components
versus mvvm and if we look at or really
a and also we look at angular to start
with as usual motor components have a
template inside my
I have a my - other - component and it
just works if my - other - components is
registered in this module or in another
module that also has that component as
exportable out of that module and this
module takes dependency on that other
module yep
that wasn't very complicated - a very
hard thing but basically you have to
configure everything for this to work so
my other component is awesome and it's
not going to complain unless you forget
to configure everything to fit together
so that my - other - component is
available oh really I go says so we
don't have just globally available
components we actually have local
components as well just as we have in
angular with components registered in
the module but not in the exports and
one when they're not registered global
components you have an element called
require so inside of my template for
this view and all templates you know
really has to be surrounded by a
template tag it says I want you to go
and require from - slash my - other and
then it goes and says my - other is
probably going to be a JavaScript file
so I'll just download the my - other Jas
file and that's my view model and then
it's going to download my - other HTML
which is my template for that view model
and then out of that my - other dot JS
file is going to look and it's going to
find an exported class called my other
with Pascal casing then it says Pascal
casing my other turns into my - other
for the view so it basically takes
Pascal casing and converts it to -
casing or kabob the casing or whatever
you want to call it
by convention or I can go in and
globally make it available so this thing
is available everywhere and I don't need
to do to require but if I do require I
can then just use my others so inside
each one of my views or my templates I
can go and say I need these other things
as well and it's pretty explicit what it
needs to load syntax wise and
they're very similar in what they can do
the only difference is do you like to
use weird characters or do you like to
use dots because if you're on the
angular side if you want to bind the
href link you put brackets around it
brackets is telling angle that this is a
one-way binding from my view model to my
view get it straight for me and you'll
really assess atreus bind href turbine
tells Aurelia that I want to bind the
the a tree has a property that's pretty
obvious to this thing here and the bind
thing is smart enough to figure out that
href is a one-way binding it only goes
from the view model to the view so I'll
only set other one while binding for you
you can explicitly say href two-way and
Rach ref dot one way and a tree F dot
one time to get different types of
bindings but by default you generally
just go eight reps of mine for writing
out text to use handlebars or mustache
syntax with double double curly braces
on the angular side and really I said no
we're doing the expo script slight way
because X my script has the dollar curly
brace as a standard notation for string
interpolation in Equus crypt so they
thought they would use the standard I
don't know if it makes a difference but
they have a difference in text and if
you want to do events you want to listen
to clicks or updates and things like
that in angular you do parentheses
around whatever event you want to listen
to and you tell it what should happen
and on the earlier side you say click
your trigger or clicks of Delegates and
you give it what should happen I do
believe that my code here is wrong
because I do believe it's supposed to be
clicked not delegate in this case
because they're kind of cool in the way
that they save some potential issues you
know really aware in if you use click
the trigger I think it's this way around
if you just click the trigger it creates
an event handler on this button if you
use click delegates they actually set up
a single event handler at the top of the
page so if you have a bunch of different
click event handlers for a bunch of
different buttons on the same page they
will actually just set up a single
handler at the
of the page and let the event bubble up
and when it comes to talk they will
figure out what button was click and
then call you so you don't end up with
15 20 different click handers you get
one and they will make sure there's more
efficient and then some events you can't
do that with so you should always use
that bubbling thing unless you can't use
that bubbling thing in and then you need
to use the other one and when is that I
don't know
read HTML spec it's easy to find out and
what else will be like a two-way data
mining on a real yes value don't bind
which is the syntax to recognize and
they're saying it's a value on an input
that's a two-way data-binding I will set
up two-way data-binding for you on the
angular side they said no we're going to
use a very weird syntax which is bracket
parentheses ng-model parentheses
brackets and it has to be brackets
before parentheses because otherwise it
doesn't work anybody want to forget that
yes every single time I write this I
keep pressing myself what or was it it's
AC it's called the banana in a box of
syntax yep I am not kidding you that is
the official syntax name for that syntax
and that's one reason not to use it but
that sets up a two-way data-binding
and also requires you to take dependency
on an extra module so two-way
data-binding is not in angular by
default you actually need a separate
module for two-way data money and then
we have something called hash-bang t be
named the hash bang thing it basically
says I want to have a local variable in
my template that points towards this
input field and then later in life my
template I can then write TB name dot
value to get the value property of the
input field it's a local variable inside
my template and oh really I said we
support that too but we got a better
syntax because we say elements or dress
that people can understand and it does
same thing what else we got
and Heisey show things is pretty cool
very very common to do angular size you
do the absolute there's no more stage
out there I'm just going to move sorry
asterisk ng is another one in this cool
character
I guess most of you guys are from Norway
right yep
so you probably have a keyboard very
similar to mine yep does it suck to do
weird characters yes because you end up
doing this thing all the time it's just
stupid get an English keyboard much much
better and then you can't write a
Norwegian which sucks so you're stuck in
nowhere it's just going to work but so
if you go with aurélia you don't have to
sit there like this the entire day
trying to figure out what to click or
present because it really I went and
said we're going to use our dot notation
so we're just going to a store but if
the bind so we're going to do bind it's
a binding F and it's for F so will do if
don't mind since thanks for repeating
things asterisk ng for equals let X of
items that's very simple let X of items
is standard a equal script six cents in
tax for a full of loop dot a for in loop
butter for all but there's also a little
a type a you think the end so angular
actually expects you to expose
observable objects out of your view
models or your components and then let
your template handle the fact that they
are a sink that is kind of cool and it
has a massive benefits because you don't
mess up and cause a memory leak and
apparently memory leaks are bad doing
this everything just works on the really
aside they're saying no you can you have
to handle all of it yourself with a
thing stuff on the other hand we don't
use observable everywhere so it's
actually quite easy on the relay side
and there since X is repeated for X of
items so it's not very very calm this is
different from the anger side so I'm
actually not going to be building
anything because we have a slightly
short session here but I do want to show
you just a little bit about the
configuration stuff I was talking about
so I'm going to go here into Austin
really so if we look at angular to begin
with open code here will open code here
there it is and we'll just see if code
will actually let me do something today
so
the second one it's getting better my
machine used to have to reboot restart
code via code twice every time I open an
angular project for some reason it's
down to one now so this is a standard
project I haven't done a whole lot the
only thing I've done is I've gone into
the source and started writing my app so
in here my main TS you see that
bootstrapping stuff that I showed you
with platform browser dynamic bootstrap
module and all of that that's proper
just angular out of box and then I
started writing my application so I have
an app in here and inside my app I have
a let's close it down I have an app
module and inside my app module I go and
I import all of the other modules I need
time for the browser module ng module to
do the decorated forms module they
stream audio the router module my
spotify module that I built I imported
my some components and a whole bunch of
things and then I went in here I said
this is my module and I've got one
component in here my app component I
require all of these other modules and
remember browser modules should always
just be in your root module and then you
choose common module and everything else
because there's a weirdness there and I
have to register and say that the app
component can be used for bootstrapping
and I create some routes up here to do
my routing for my navigation basically
saying that when you go to slash modify
show this component when you go to slash
nothing redirect to slash modify and
then I register my routes here using the
router module to get everything going
app components very simple thing later a
very simple thing doesn't do a whole lot
it just points to the template URL the
file URL and a selector that should be
what you used to show this this
component and it has a very very simple
template where it basically says here's
a title that's data bound and here is
where I want to do all of my navigation
not very complicated but there is a bit
there's still a bit of stuff going on in
here with registering other modules and
components and then I went and I built a
module on my own because I like Spotify
and their API
is really cool to work with so I create
a Spotify module once again import all
of the modules to donate create import
the service that I've created to do my
searches import my all of my components
that I've got set up my module declare
that I want want these two other modules
these components here are available in
this module but only this component is
allowed to be used outside this module
and oh by the way here's also a Spotify
service if you need to do anything with
a service actual implementation of
everything is actually quite simple it's
just a simple component as the template
has a search thing is and I expose a
promise in this case I actually expose
the asynchronous operation straight into
the view and then in my component here
so I data bind that in here into another
component but the main important thing
here is to have a look at the all of
your registration stuff there's not a
lot of registration in here because I
only have like two components but when
you start writing this code and you keep
adding new components adding new
functionality you keep jumping back and
forth between adding a new component
here and then I have to go and register
that thing there and I have to remember
to register this module over here and
then you go and compare that to Orillia
and I know I sound very pro aurélia
that's because I like to point out the
things that are different and they have
some really cool stuff so what really a
does instead is that that reboots as
well in their app 30s which is where
they start they just go ahead and say I
have some router configuration stuff
that needs to be done so here's my
router configuration looks pretty much
the same but instead of having to import
the my different components and stuff I
just give it you give it passed so this
is where you what this is the path
relative to this thing where you will
find the view model that I wanted to
load and then it automatically figures
out that if you want to go and guess dot
slash fortify slice fortified I search
you want to get the JavaScript file for
this view model and you want to get HTML
file for the template it just figures it
out for me and inside my main PS I say I
have a feature called Spotify so I need
to register my fate research
but I give it the name of that soldier
it looks into that spotify folder it
finds an indica TS file by convention it
should have one of these these functions
and here I say anybody that uses this
feature should have this view model
available for use an inside Spotify
search notes what if I search I have
this class here called Spotify search
and convention based says that Spotify
search in classical casing becomes
Spotify search using kebab casing and
whenever you want to show that in the UI
you just use Spotify search in kebab
casing inside of an element and you're
done there's no other configuration
going on here I don't have to tell it
anything service for example the Spotify
service I created this thing here I do
have to add an auto-injector saying that
I want you to do dependency injection in
this class so whenever this thing is
instantiated I want you to go ahead and
dependency inject it but the cool thing
is that the actual service is not
registered anywhere there's no
registration of what services are
available this is just a class whenever
I want to use it I go and I pull in my
Spotify service up here from the path i
order inject it and I put it up as a
constructor parameter and really I will
just go and say oh so you asked for an
instance of this thing you probably mean
that that is a services you want me to
instantiate and it goes in essentially
for you without you having to register
it and you can also go in and make some
changes and say this should be a
singleton this should be a transient one
and you can change the way that your
services are handled where their
lifetime example so this is a lot less
of the boilerplate configuration stuff
than you will get in angular when you
snow really anybody write this because I
hope viously don't do you just saw that
when I create an application for you
guys to love creating tests and love
creating JavaScript tests also calls
masochist and you have all of that pre
set up both of the frameworks use Jasmin
and karma for your unit tests
for m10 tests they both use Jasmine and
protractor the it's even at the point
where I think that really uses a
protractor fork that angular has created
so there órale is really piggybacking on
angular's work within the protractor
stuff that's pretty much the same
nothing
expect actually between the frameworks
building stuff I got really annoyed by
building stuff which is why I've put
this slide in here and I want to see
which one is most complicated to build
anybody find building JavaScript
applications complicated nowadays
there's three hands and then a whole
bunch of people have never built
JavaScript applications it sucks so I
pull it out and I figure out okay so
angular has to see a lie so you do see a
lie and you do a you build and it's
built it for you no sorry ng build is
built it for you and it uses web pack
behind the scenes but you don't have to
care it just works
it's like Mac and if you want to let's
take a while before somebody if you want
to do ng x you get the web pack file and
you're in web pack land and then use
webpack or you can go and use system Jas
and manually configure everything
anybody ever try that I did if you did
that never do it again if you have an
application using angular that you -
that uses systemjs right now go home and
change it before you go to the next
session and by the way it's going to
take you about a week to get sorted out
so don't use that web pack every single
day of the week web pack or angular CLI
which uses web pack on the real site
it's a little bit different they've
actually default to requirejs
but if you and that's if you used to see
like so if you used to see like to build
you requirejs
you can manually set up required yes or
you can go and use webpack they have
skeleton apps for web pack so you can't
use the CLI to start a new web pack
based project it will probably be in
your future and what I heard last week
from Ashley grant who is one of the core
contributor to project they are looking
at making web pack default so they are
moving to web pack as well
probably I'm just reading between the
lines they are moving to web pack but he
didn't want to say it like that it is
recorded hierarchies
isomorphic stuff so if you want to be
able to render your application on the
server and serve up static HTML which is
kind of cool you can do that in angular
I'm going to have something called
angular Universal that renders on the
server generate static HTML sense that
bounce your browser and then you can
either go ahead and add angular down set
down in the clients and basically
rehydrate your application but the user
gets all of the data straight away
instead of going here it's application
it's empty I'm now loading my angular
application it's now semi empty I do a
request to the server to get the data
and here is what you wanted to say you
can go and say here is what you wanted
to see I'll add angular and rehydrate
the thing and make it dynamic or you can
just go and say I'll just serve it up
statically so if you don't have
JavaScript activated or you happen to be
a web crawler for a search engine I will
just serve static stuff and whenever you
click a link instead of it being
dynamically navigated I will just repost
back to your server or get to your
server and get a static version back it
really doesn't have that in a moment but
they've said that it's on the way so
hopefully it will be in the future they
have a they have a proof of concept but
apparently they didn't like the way it
works so they're working on something
else I also tried to get the angular and
oh really are compared with Phi's just
for the heck of it so I went and ng and
aged you new create a new project I
built it according to prod which is
basically production settings on angular
you do ang build - prod for production
and - - IOT to do a header type compile
which makes your application a little
bit smaller and if has to be much faster
in the browser and it ends up being four
files by default after I remove the
forms bundle and it ends up being 312
kilobytes if I do not I don't suck at
math but I think it does and then I went
and do the same thing for Aurelia and it
comes out as two packages and it's one
kilobyte plus 3 is 395 through 396 if
312 to 395 kilobytes is a problem for
you because Aurelia is 80 kilobytes
heavier than
angular first of all you're wrong
because it doesn't matter that much
because 80 kilobytes most people can
handle that second of all you shouldn't
be using any of these frameworks which
that's a problem because we're looking
at half a mag not really but 400 K
before you've even loaded your own stuff
there so when you start building your
stuff this is just going to grow assume
you will probably in a slightly larger
application end up with JavaScript
reaching the amount of maybe a Meg ish
if you don't do a ot and production
builds actually do just builds on your
local machine and M the angular
application ends up at something like
2.4 Meg's
javascript is heavy apparently so what
about documentation anybody love
documentation in open source projects
anybody find out the source project
often lacking in the area of
documentation I will give a big gold
star to a person that gets involved in
the local source project and just as
documentation I need to find more of
those people just go around the world
crawling for open source project and
write documentation I would love you so
I looked at them and it's kind of cool
because they both have awesome
documentation they both have registered
io domains so we know that they are cool
that's number one has to be an i/o and
Aurelia has a bit more of fluff a bit
more how do I get started installing
those and installing my environment and
getting basically up to speed
whereas angular doesn't have that but
they have auto built samples so when
they release a new version the samples
on their web page or apparently
automatically rebuilt and redone and
tested and everything so that the code
on their web page will always work in
the latest version that they've released
that is cool but that's a technical geek
thingy so other than that it's pretty
much even what about the community
actually smacked me regarding this
because I compared them on the community
and I thought II thought that I was
wrong and I was so I tried to make it
better and I was wrong again but I'll
try my best
it's actually quite hard to compare
community apparently I went to github
angular puts all
all of their stuff into one repo so all
of their modules are in one repo which
makes it ridiculously easy to go in and
say how many commits have you guys got
how many issues do you have and how many
contributes do you have so there are
about 7800 as of yesterday commits to
angular's repo and 1440 issues and then
really at know a reality sites that have
one repo per module which makes it
really hard to figure out what the
committee commit count is and stuff like
that so I somebody had written a cool
NPM module that would actually get
everything from Orillia which then gives
me commits that are not into Aurelia but
into other or really issue things so
it's it's slightly off but they end up
at 4800 having that said angular also
includes the angular website so they're
both freakish offs but what I want to
come up with is there's more stuff
happening on angular on github than
there is on this side
contributors I have no idea I didn't
even get there it was just too hard to
do I went to stack overflow anybody go
to stack overflow it happens right most
of us do yeah it's like overflows
awesome if it's on stack overflow
you're good so angular 49 thousand seven
hundred plus questions about angular
when you search for it fifty-five
thousand two hundred are tagged with
angular 2 oh really a 5100 if you search
and two thousand two thousand three
hundred if you look for tags there's
apparently more stuff happening on the
angler side of things Ashley's
suggestion to this is one that I also
try to use which is interesting you can
always twist numbers right can you
imagine how good or real yes when they
only needed half as many commits to
become perfect they have way less bugs
and it's so easy to use that there's way
let there let way less questions on
Stack Overflow so it's just there are
there are no problems with your
framework I have a different
interpolation of the numbers and I think
you do too
but it's one way of looking at backing
and behind Aurelia you've got this blue
spire which is an
consultant agency that consults on
really
they build Orillia and they have
consultancy where you can go and get
stuff build it with or really and you
can get professional help from those
guys angular has a small company called
Google Google has a staff of full-time
employees working on angular or really
has open source with as far as I know
not a single full-time person on the
framework this is a little bit of a
difference between who's behind it
and I assume considering the conference
we're at that you are Microsoft
developers right so we like Microsoft
things what happens when your front end
web developer and you say that you work
with Microsoft technologies not you're
wrong note everything is now official
studio you're wrong just throw that out
I use a screen that no no wrong just
skip that note and it's kind of like
that on the angular size there's very
little information on how to get angular
to work nicely together with a snap and
a snake or it's not hard but there's
just very little documentation on it on
the real side they will actually help
you so if you do a you new - - here
inside of a folder that's an asset core
application they will set up and act
really application configured to work
together with a snare core and copy
things to write folders and all your
bills will work so they do help out they
even have skeleton apps that will use a
standard course so there's a bit of
Microsoft love in there and if you want
to use a other Microsoft stuff have a
look at these templates here phrase net
for that is Steve Sanderson is built
they are awesome they have pre-built
templates for visual studio and leads to
your code for react angular view and
something else and they have all the
bells and whistles and it's really hard
to understand but Steve is smarter than
me so what's my conclusion that is kind
of my conclusion it's it's a heavyweight
thing against a lightweight open
sourcing a very few people behind it but
perfect is my conclusion is that if you
like conventions and mvvm go Orillia if
you like configuration and components go
angular
if you feel that you want something
that's easy to use getting started with
it's just everything kind of just falls
into place if you do just name things
right or really is the way to go it's
really easy to use releases you get
started with but they do have a lacking
community if you need help there's not
as much to get if you like doing
configuration components you want have a
big community easy to get help
angular way to go I really wanted to
come out at the end is there you should
choose X I can they are too similar they
do both things all things pretty much
well they do the same things so you can
choose whatever you want to be perfectly
honest that's pretty much everything I
have to say and I'm one minute past I
think but I hope you got something out
of it if you have any questions I will
be around here now and later on and
tomorrow so just come and tap me on the
shoulder and ask any questions of Deb
thank you
[Applause]